just want to make a quick update video
for this YouTube channel because over
the last couple weeks I have not posted
any videos and I just got back from a
long and tiring trip throughout Europe I
think the last video I posted here was
from the Beale tournament I recap my
final round game but since then it's
been a lot of traveling for me I went to
Germany for the World Chess tennis
championship
and then I went to Italy for a friend's
wedding and it's just been a lot of
hopping around between different places
but now that I'm back I'm looking
forward to getting back on a regular
content grind between YouTube videos and
live streaming on Twitch and I wanted to
ask for your help and your feedback if
there's any particular types of videos
that you like to see in the coming days
and weeks please do let me know I have a
ton of over-the-board footage that I
recorded in Europe that I'm looking
forward to going through and editing but
apart from that if you want to see any
other sorts of content between
instructional opening videos or more
competitive online tournaments really
anything that you want to see on this
channel let me know in the comments I'll
be reading all of them and I do
appreciate everyone's patience as I've
taken a small break from YouTube but do
stay tuned for more content and one last
thing but tomorrow tomorrow I'm
recording this on August 20th so August
21st there's going to be a streamer
battle on leeches
and what that is it's a two hour Blitz
tournament anyone can join and represent
my team I'll leave links in the video
description of how to join my team and
the tournament but I would love it if
you join and you fight for me we'll be
taking on teams representing other
streamers so should be a ton of fun I'll
be streaming the whole thing on Twitch
so hope to see you there and hope to see
you in future videos as well stay tuned